[Music]
today reviewing the rtx 3050. this card
sat quietly on the shelf and watched as
we ran tests on the rx 6500xt
and muttered horrible things under our
breaths as we watched the card suffer
through one test after another and no
doubt this 3050 has been wondering
what its fate will be in today's review
we're gonna find out this is an rtx 3050
xc asterisk evga and nvidia up
the launch
but we do still have a card to review
before that this video is brought to you
by arctic and the liquid freezer 2 line
of liquid coolers which tested among the
best in our thermal charts for cpu
coolers the arctic liquid freezer series
has had continual advancement since our
original review with updates in the
mounting kit including an amd offset
bracket for better thermals and a longer
warranty arctic also has its mx-5
thermal compound available on the market
now if you need some thermal paste for
your regular maintenance learn more at
the links in the description below
so just before we get into this every
evga rtx 3050 that was sent out for
review as we've been told by the
companies had a mistake and and oops
where they applied a v bios that's
intended for a card whose msrp is 50
higher than what we thought this one
would cost so this card uh in this state
should be a 250 card msrp we're ignoring
all the other stuff right now that means
that the clock should be much lower than
what it actually was running this card
was actually running a frequency that is
intended for something like an xc ultra
or some overclocked pre-overclocked
factory overclocked xc card where the
price will be 50 higher than msrp so
it'll be 330
higher price higher msrp for basically
higher clocks out of the box now
fortunately evga and nvidia were kind
enough to tell us about this about
maybe 12 hours before we needed to start
filming which is after we had completed
multiple days of testing on the device
and with the general display of
competence on show here we
decided we would run with what we have
and instead go off of an msrp of 330
since that's basically what we tested it
boils down to this ebj offered another v
bios
we don't have infinite time and we can't
go back in time to start running tests
that will literally not be possible to
complete before the review goes up the
review is still valid the data is still
valid uh we are however instead looking
at a card that is above msrp for the rtx
3050 line the performance difference
between the 250 and the 330 cards is
about two to three percent so this 330
version is about two to three percent
better than the 250 version they did
send out the other v bios but
you know we're just going to review it
as if it's the card it actually is which
is the more expensive one okay so as we
get into this we've got two test benches
we're working with right now we are
transferring all of our data from our
old test bench which is a gen 3 platform
to our new test bench was a gen 4
platform with the 12700 kf that means
that we're going to show multiples of
each game as we go through gen 3 and gen
4 test bench data eventually we're going
to transfer all of it over to our new
test bench but because it's so long to
run each card it's an iterative process
and it takes time to build the data set
so we've got the older data set that we
you have more cards to compare to like
gtx 1070s 960s 970s
980 ti's even things of that nature and
then the new data set where it's
completely fresh but is more limited in
the cards you can compare to let's get
started with this we'll look at the
frequency plot first since that's where
they screwed up uh and just again to
reiterate
this is still a thing that's going to
shift it's not like they've
overclocked it to a point where it's
it's no longer a realistic card this is
a car that ships um it's just not the
one that they thought it was going to be
so let's get started after we had
already completed the two days of
testing on the rtx 3050 evga and nvidia
sent us that email we mentioned earlier
where they said they accidentally
shipped a higher clocked version of the
cart this plot confirms that it is in
fact an over performing v bios for the
card that it was shipped on the good
news is that this card will exist
if anything this will reflect poorly on
evga for its value here since the extra
two to three percent performance from
the frequency boost costs a lot more
money at a 50 increase as you can see
from the line that's been drawn the
average frequency is around 2000
megahertz for the rtx 3050. we have
another rtx card on here as well just
for a point of reference shadow of the
tomb raider is up next test it on our
older bench first which has the 6500xt
slightly disadvantaged due to its pcie
limitations but this was a choice amd
made so the chart looks like this for
1080p the rtx 3050 xc card including the
v bios bump to a higher msrp ran at 92
fps average here that has it about seven
percent better than a gtx 1070 which
sold for around 380 when it first
launched this card is 330 msrp and it's
coming out
six years later than the equivalently
performing 380 gtx 1070. the rtx 2060
leads the 30 50 by 20 tier the rx 6600
had a 119 fps average result leading the
30 50 by 30
there's a meaningful uplift for the 3050
versus the gtx 1060 the gtx 970 and the
gtx 960 and obviously anything older
than that as for the rx 6500 xt that
remains pointless and then for owners of
a gtx 1070 or better you obviously have
no need to buy a 3050. this chart is
only for the 6500 xt really it gains a
bit here we're on gen 4 now so this is
the newer test bench it closes the gap a
little bit it allows the 30 50 a 30 lead
instead of a 48 lead against the gen 3
result at 1440p on the gen 3 bench the
rtx 3050 landed at 63 fps average still
playable here that has it right between
the rx 5600 xt and the gtx 1070 with the
rtx 2060 leading by about 18 percent
here the rtx 3060 currently selling for
about 700 to 800 on ebay leads the rtx
3050 by about 35
depending on the price gap on the street
the upgrade would push you closer to 4k
performance in some lighter games or
higher fps 1440p results up next in
rainbow six siege at 1080p the rtx 3050
ran at about 229 fps average lows are
well spaced and fine they're roughly
proportional to the average so that
looks good here too for comparison the
rtx 2060 held at 247 fps average leading
the rtx 3050 by 8 in average fps this
lead is significantly smaller than what
we saw in tomb raider and establishes a
lower bout the rtx 3050 is about eight
percent ahead of the gtx 1070
establishing a marker for equivalence to
pascal's generation as for the 6500 xt
that gets left behind at 180 fps average
but it's far behind what we're looking
at up the chart the 3050 for example
holds a 29 lead in that comparison at
1440p the rtx 3050 held 142 fps average
still more than playable leading the gtx
1660 by 20 and the gtx 1070 by 7
the rx 6600 xt leads by about 32 when
stock for perspective against amd on our
newer test bench but with the same game
and 1440p resolution the rx 6600 non-xt
led the 3050 by about 9.7
this in turn led the 6500xt gen 4 result
by 41 tested at 4k the rtx 3050 ran at
70 fps average it's actually very close
to the gtx 1070 about seven percent
ahead for the 30 50 here and the rx 5600
xt was also close by and that's one from
the last generation the rx 5600xt was
briefly a 280 card just as a reminder
although obviously it's been a while in
red dead redemption 2 at 1080p and on
the gen 3 bench the rtx 3050 ran at 70
fps average leading the gtx 1070 by a
much larger 19 margin than we saw in
rainbow six testing this puts the once
300 rtx 2060 ko about 12 percent ahead
of the rtx 3050. not great for value but
you've heard this story constantly for
the last two years compared to amd the
rx 6600 non-xt offers a 30 lead over the
3050 while the 6600 xt jumps 50 percent
for users on the rx 480 or rx 580 you
can expect an improvement in the range
of 27 to the rtx 3050. in the newer gen
4 testing platform but with the same
everything the rtx 3050 landed at about
the same 71 fps average perfectly
playable here and it still led the 6500
xt gen 4 result by 30
that card already embarrassed itself
enough when it equated an rx 580 though
uh which is a refresh by the way of the
2016 rx 480 so
we'll move on compared to the gtx 1660
the rtx 3050 offers an 18 uplift here at
1440p performance falls to 54 fps
average but that's still in playable
range while being on relatively high or
custom high settings you could drop
settings slightly and hit 60 but 54 is
realistically fine here the lows start
to struggle a little bit and we do see
some occasional blips and frame time
consistency but the experience overall
is fine to good total war 3 kingdoms is
next tested at 1080p we use ultra
settings for this benchmark which is
done to create extreme load on gpus and
show scaling in the future we like to do
this with at least one game per cycle to
give long-term comparisons the rtx 3050
at 49 fps average put it close to the
gtx 980 ti and the gtx 1070 from
previous generations gtx 980 ti owners
should feel
awfully smug right now alternatives
would be the 30 60 at 44 better than
average fps or the 6600 non-xt at 26
uplift and 62 fps average the 65 xt is
distant and can be ignored here at 1440p
the 30fps average result puts the card
about the same as a gtx 1070. the rtx
3060 class cards remain in roughly
playable territory both ti and non-ti as
does the rx 6600 xt and it establishes
the closest modern alternatives for a
step up you can expect 44 to about 60
better performance between the 30 60 and
the 6600 xt respectively or about double
the average fps in a 30 60 ti and less
smoother frame time consistency and
horizon zero dawn at 1080p we measured
an 82 fps average with lows still
overall fine the stack is similar to
before the 2060 is about a 17 lead the
6600 is about 21 percent ahead of the
3050 and the rtx 3060 and rx 6600 xt
are both about 38 percent ahead the 3050
leads the 6500 xt on gen 3 by 34 percent
the 1660 super is about the same as the
30 50 and that's formerly a 230 card by
the way but to be fair it had no rtx
capabilities and it's not 230 dollars
now the gen 4 result helps the 6500 xt a
bit bringing it up to 70 fps average
from around 60 fps average on gen 3.
this has it closer to the 30 50 but the
3050 still leads significantly in the
division 2 at 1080p the rtx 3050 held at
104 fps average showing a reduced
distance from the 2060 and 6600 than in
some of the other tests the 2060 is 14
percent ahead the 6600 non-xt is 25
ahead and the 3050 leads the 1660 super
by 13
the rtx 3050 is right between the 1660
super and the rtx 2060 ko at 1440p the
3050 held 68 fps average and had
consistent frame time pacing that's
fully playable without any real issues
the 3050 ends up a bit ahead of the gtx
1070 and spaced apart from the 2060 and
up by the same percentages as before or
roughly far cry 6 is next for this one
we only test with our gen 4 platform
right now we don't use extra texture
packs and testing and just test the
stock game on high settings the rtx 3050
landed at 88 fps average which means the
2060 is about 13 ahead and that's on the
lower side of the average thus far the
3050 is ahead of the 6500xt gen4 by 16
here at 1440p the 3050 drops 26 percent
of its performance from 1080p expectedly
but maintains an overall playable
average frame times aren't as good but
they are at least mostly consistent the
hierarchical stack remains about the
same in gta 5 on the gen 3 bench the rtx
3050 ran at 109 fps average with our
settings making it about the same an
average one percent and 0.1 lows as the
1660 super the rtx 2060 still holds a 17
lead over the 30 50 in this one for
power consumption testing at the pcie
cables and the pcie slot we saw the 30
50 at about 134 watts stock that's
including evj's boosted v bios or 149
watts when overclocked on the stock side
that has it consuming about the same
power as the 6600 swift or swift or
whatever the missing vowel is so that's
it then we're getting a little worn down
here but you get the idea for our
conclusions which is that uh the value
is obviously still going in a negative
direction that's not good the rtx 2060
ko puts this thing
to shame in disgusting ways uh it
shouldn't even be allowed on youtube but
how much this gets disgraced by the 2060
where it's eight to 30 percent better
than the 3050 is in rasterization
results and yet at the same time the
2060 ko is a card that we bought for 300
when it came out and this is 330
so you know where we stand on this
wrapping it all up then uh certainly our
opinion of the
ability to handle a launch hasn't
improved but
beyond that what we know is that the
retail versions are supposed to have the
correct bios is installed so if you buy
the xc black it's going to be the stock
frequency one and the xc ultra or
whatever it's ultimately called will be
basically what we reviewed here today
but the performance difference doesn't
matter a ton a couple percentage points
so where do we end up
we end up with uh 2060 is anywhere from
about
seven percent to 30 ahead of the 30 50.
depends on the game and the resolution
but that's the very wide range we saw if
we narrow that down to more of an
average in aggregate the 2060 tends to
be closer to about 13 to 16 percent
ahead of the 30 50 in our testing and
the low metric scale mostly linearly
between the two so it's proportional so
that's about the difference there that's
with 2060 ko which was once a 300 card
obviously not anymore but that's what it
was the 1660 super is similar in
performance to the rtx 3050 plus or
minus a bit depending on the game but
they're mostly comparable directly and
the 6500 xt is left behind as one might
expect from a card which has had half of
its features cut off the gtx 1070 is
shockingly close in performance in the
test we ran versus the 3050 so
and the 980 ti as well is pretty close
so as we said if you're a 90 ti owner
you should be pretty smug right now
because you're still doing pretty well
since your card which was something like
500 maybe 600 when you bought it
not even adjusting for inflation
is is now about the same as a car that's
going to retail for close to 400
many years later like like
five six five six years later something
like that um and certainly this will be
even more expensive in the street so
that's where it lines up hopefully
that's enough to help you figure out if
you actually want to buy it or not
it's it's still
hard to review some of these cards right
now sometimes they make it easy the
6500xc certainly made it easy because it
drew a
very clear line in the sand
of
just
how little it was willing to give for
basic features for users who are buying
it this one
we have the same stance we do as all the
other ones it's just you start getting
beaten down over time
which the stance is the value is
obviously going in a negative direction
direction it's a regression from the
past few years in value we've been
saying this for a couple of years now uh
this does appear to be this status quo
at this point
so
maybe the upside would be to look at it
as
but is it going in a negative direction
at a slower pace as
has the acceleration slowed on the
regression in value and
maybe it depends what it sells for i
don't know
i it's hard to review a product based on
information that will not exist until
after it actually launches and ends up
on
ebay's digital shelves so look we're
going to be straight up with you
these gpu launches right now we're still
going to review the cards we're going to
test them and
our goal is mostly if it's really stupid
like the 6500 xt wise like the new
gt730s are will tell you
if it's kind of nebulous or it's in the
middle or whatever
then we'll give you the percent
differences versus other cards that you
can make an informed decision still you
still get value out of the review and
the data but
also we're going to shift and we have
been shifting our focus to other
components that we're more interested in
because the gpu market's been just
burning everyone and and
it's clear that you know we have very
limited time with the small staff we
have and the depth we provide and so
we've been looking at the situation now
as this is the time to start investing
in fan testing and really figure that
out we've been putting off fan testing
open loop testing
expanding our acoustic testing to
include
frequency spectrum analysis we've been
putting that off for years now because
we've done such depth on gps in the past
where we'd wire them all up with
thermocouples we would do
uh
schlieren imaging testing and all this
other cool stuff pressure map testing
cold plate flatness testing our 3080 gpu
review was insane it was one of the most
in-depth reviews i've ever produced for
gn
um but
it's clear that right now the market is
still in a weird position where it's
kind of
to some mix to a to a limit which
apparently is a 65 xt because that
remained in stock for a while to a limit
people will buy something if it's kind
of good enough
because your options have been limited
and what that says to us is this is a
good time to invest our efforts into
other cool stuff that you all will
appreciate you all have been asking us
for for years and now is the time to
capitalize on that and use
the the reduced interest in things like
reviews for this that include pressure
maps and flatness testing ancillary
imaging where people don't care anymore
or don't care to the same extent because
the comparative between cards doesn't
matter if you're just buying what's
available to you
and invest that into something
productive which is all the other
components we want to get into so just
trying to be
fully up front with everyone that uh
we've given you the percent differences
you know where it lands but we can also
read the room and we see a lot of
interest in other components so we're
exploring more of that excited to do it
anyway this thing is kind of yeah like i
said eight to thirty percent
advantage uh 2060 versus this
um average 13 to 16 percent the 1660
super similar to 65 xd behind 1070 is
very close that's about it for you
thanks for watching subscribe for the
other stuff like our fantastic we posted
some youtube stories recently showing it
we've got it set up and we're running it
now really excited about that happy to
share it check back for that go to
store.camerasexus.net to grab something
like a toolkit and we'll see you all
next time